[Music]
Hallie Bailey AKA Princess Ariel sneaks
into a screening of The Little Mermaid
opening weekend something about you
seems different I can't quite figure it
out on Tick Tock the actress reveals how
she went Incognito at the movie theater
wearing a face mask and sunglasses look
at this truth treasure Sun tone how many
wonders can one Cavern hold yeah clearly
a good disguise as film goers had no
idea Ariel was literally part of their
feels absolutely amazing to I think that
it's something that we have all just had
in our Dream the Disney Princess made it
into the screening without making a
splash you want thing in my box I got
20.
but who care Hallie writes in the
caption can't believe the little mermaid
is the number one movie in the world you
guys the first 20 minutes I was like
jaw dropped and just like tears like
non-stop flowing because you know I
consider myself a musician and singer
first I never seen myself on this big
screen before so it's like all of these
things and emotions and wow that's me
like oh that's a little cringe that
moment there and then also like that's
really me I'm proud of myself and
Holly's got lots to be proud of Disney's
latest live action flick had a great
opening weekend earning an estimated
117.5 million domestically and 185
million worldwide
[Music]
part of yours
The Little Mermaid also made history
it's the highest grossing opening ever
for a film with a black female lead
beating Jordan peels us with Lupita
nyango which opened to 71.1 million in
2019. was there anything else that you
said like I need to make sure I stay
true to myself in this way yes well I
think naturally I just really tried my
best to stay true to myself
and every choice that I would make in
acting and especially in the songs
but I know something's starting right
now
you know I was really grateful to Rob
Marshall that he gave me the freedom to
just be me and seeing how Hallie would
sing and some of those inflections and
riffs I was allowed to do and that was
fun to be able to play because the
original music that we have is so
beautiful such a staple in all of our
childhoods and the fact that I got to
tweak and edit it a little bit was like
so much fun and a joy to have that
creative freedom whether Halley's
on-screen flipping her fins I just want
to know more about them or swimming
through the crowd at a local theater
sure
he's got everything
Hallie you can be part of our world
anytime
[Music]
foreign